I'm thinking about all the small places
I put myself to for men.
Wow I should go call my therapist
and have a conversation about this.
Yeah 100%, I know, why do we do that, right?
Like I struggle, not struggle
but I find myself always contemplating
how is it that someone, like
I think of myself as very fortunate
that I was raised by this very strong mom, she's a broad.
She's like the quintessential broad.
And so there's like the strength that always came
with me just growing up around her and seeing her.
And yet, you know, I found myself
in my twenties and in my early thirties,
like and I think back like
how I tried to make myself smaller
for a guy or in a relationship
because you think that's ultimately the problem.
And like, if you can like, just be a little bit smaller
not live your full potential
and just be okay with just being a little bit less
like everything will be okay.
And it's like, what?
What are we thinking?
That's ridiculous.
It's hard.
Like unless you're dating someone of an equal thing
and I, I,
but it's not like I I've just had such a struggle with men.
I have a lot to talk to (mumbles), my therapist about later.
Like,
(laughs)
and by the way.
Can we do it two for one?
Yes, yes.
(laughs)
And by the way, I was watching "Long Shot" the other night
and I just loved it and I was having such a good time.
And I love watching, you know, for me comedy
if I wasn't, you know, if I didn't have comedy
or I didn't seek comedy
or I didn't immerse myself in the pool of comedy,
I'd be in a straight jacket.
I say it all the time, hanging upside down like a bat.
(laughs)
In fact, what, what's your favorite funny movie
or what are your favorite funny movies?
Oh my gosh.
So just recently I had a little bit of dental surgery
and so I had some downtime
and I re-watched "Planes, Trains and Automobiles".
That was like one of my favorite, favorite movies
but I haven't seen it in years.
Oh my God.
How? I mean, you have to watch it again.
It is so good.
It's a masterpiece.
And I quote it all the time.
The other day I was at work
and Frankie had her first day of kindergarten
and I was here and I have made, you know
every class visit and you know, everything.
But of course not the hundred things I've gotten to do
and showed up for, the one thing I had to miss was like
I was like I am the worst parent.
And I was like, oh my God.
And Chris Miller looked at me and it's the scene where
Steve Martin is saying
he's missing his daughter's school play.
And John Candy goes, oh yeah those moments,
they don't come back.
Yeah.
And so of course,
Chris busted that out.
It's a masterpiece.
I love that movie so much.
I love that if I want to think about the good in the world
I can think of you.
I want to, if I want to think about the sexy and fierce
and capacity of the world, I can think of you.
I feel that way about you
and you impress me on so many different levels.
Like I can't even start, like, I'm, I'm obsessed with your,
your beauty regime on Instagram.
Like I, like, I can't get enough of that.
Like, it's basically my, it's my Bible now.
It's so incredible.
And then you'll have to tell me why your hair is so shiny.
Oh, thank you.
I found this new shampoo
and it is making my hair shiny and lustrous.
Also, Mr. Daniel sang a real tune on it
and he makes it look.
I mean, by the way, your whole look right now, I'm dying.
The hair sweep and the berry makeup.
It's so beautiful, whoever, if you did it
or whoever did it, kudos.
So yeah I mean, definitely
I could play Quasimodo when I come in here in the morning.
Stop it, stop.
So there's definitely
a team of zhuzh-ers so,
this is I'll have Mr. Daniel send the text with me
because this is his magic,
but I'll send you the shampoo too, 'cause it's amazing.
Yeah, please.
It's your hair it looks incredible.
Well, Andy Warhol said,
you fall in love with your eyes closed.
Whether my eyes are closed or open,
I am just madly, madly in love with you.
I love you deeply, thank you.
(upbeat music)